Welcome back to the Deep Dive.
Today we are cracking open a
narrative record that is, quite
frankly, a master class in Chaos
management.
Or maybe a master class in how
not to manage chaos?
I think that's probably more
accurate, yeah.
We're looking at a log simply
titled Session 26.
It is certainly a dense text on
the surface.
If you just skim it, it reads
like a pretty standard fantasy
adventure log.
You know, fight the bad guy, get
the loot.
But when you actually sit down
and and peel back the layers,
it's a psychological case study
on desperation.
It's really about what happens
when people are backed into a
corner and start making very,
very bad decisions.
Oh absolutely.
And before we get into the nitty
gritty, we really need to set
the scene for you.
We were talking about a high
stakes fantasy narrative set in
the land of Barovia.
Now, for anyone who hasn't spent
time in this particular setting,
how would you describe Borovia?
It's not exactly a vacation
spot, is it?
Far from it, no.
Think of Borovia as a place
where the sun never quite
shines.
It is perpetually overcast.
The forests are full of wolves
that are smarter than you.
That's terrifying.
It is, and the ruler is an
ancient, incredibly powerful
vampire named Strad.
The entire atmosphere is
oppressive by design.
It's a horse that that's sort of
disguised as an adventure
setting.
Right.
It's pure gothic horror.
Everything is decaying,
everything is sad.
And in this specific session, we
are following a party of
adventurers who are, to put it
mildly, having the worst week of
their lives.
That's an understatement.
We've got a desperate heist, a
web of lies that would make a
seasoned politician blush, and a
battle that goes so wrong so
fast it forces a humiliating
retreat.
And.
You know, the objective was
actually quite surgical, at
least on paper.
They had a clear mission.
It seems simple.
It did infiltrate the home of a
noble woman named Lady Walker in
the town of Awlaki.
Their goal was to retrieve one
specific artifact, the Amulet of
Ravenkind.
Get in, get the amulet, get out.
Sounds simple.
It sounds like a classic smash
and grab.
It does, but there is a massive
elephant in the room before they
even step foot in the town, the
Hughes one.
The party is operating under a
deception that is honestly kind
of breathtaking in its audacity.
They are dragging an ally along
a guy named Ismarc who thinks
they are there for a completely
different reason.
He thinks they're there to save
his sister.
He does.
And spoiler alert for everyone
listening, they're definitely
not there to save his sister.
No, not at all.
And as we'll see, that lie is
the structural fault line that
threatens to collapse the entire
endeavor.
It's the ticking clock in the
background of every single
scene.
So before we watch this train
wreck unfold in slow motion,
let's quickly Orient ourselves
right?
Who are the people making these
terrible life choices?
We got a pretty diverse crew
here.
It's a classic adventuring
composition for the most part.
First you have your horn,
Tenpenny.
He is a halfling Beastmaster.
And he's not a alone, right?
He's got a companion.
The Beastmaster part is key.
Correct.
A great cat.
You should think of a Mountain
Lion or a Panther.
It's a significant combat asset
for sure, but it's also an
emotional anchor for him.
OK, so that's your horn.
Then there is Radley.
Radley, a human eldritch knight.
An Eldritch Knight break that
down for me.
What does that actually mean in
practice?
Think of him as the muscle, but
with a magical edge.
So he wears heavy armor.
He swings big weapons, but he
can also cast defensive spells
or you know, throw fire.
He is the tank, effectively.
Got it.
The heavy hitter.
The one you send in first.
Exactly.
Then we have Perlon, Good
Shadow, another halfling, but a
monk.
So very different from you're a
horn.
Very different.
Highly mobile, martial arts
focused.
He's the guy who runs up walls
and punches people in the face.
A whirlwind of fists.
And rounding out the main crew,
the one who's supposed to make
this whole heist thing work.
That would be Dermont Cobain and
Elfar Kane.
Trickster.
He fulfills the rogue archetype.
Stealth locks, Disarming traps.
All the classic robe stuff.
Right, but he uses magic to
enhance those thieving skills.
He can go invisible, create
illusions.
He's their key to getting in
quietly.
So we have a beastmaster, a tank
mage, a Kung Fu halfling, and a
magic thief.
And then there is is Mark.
He's the MPC, the non player
character who's just caught in
the middle of all this.
And is Mark is crucial here?
He is the new Burgo master of
the village of Barovia.
I want to pause on that word.
Burgo Master, we see a lot of
these texts.
What does that actually mean in
this context?
Is he like a mayor or is it more
than that?
He is like a mayor but with,
let's say, feudal absolute power
and a lot more wolves at his
door.
Literally, literally.
He is the civic leader
responsible for the safety of
the village, but in Barovia,
that's a curse job.
His father died from the stress
of it is Mark is young, he's
noble, and he's trying to fill
very, very big shoes.
And he is the victim of the
party's deception.
He's the one they're lying to.
He is.
He is the moral anchor that the
party has chosen to cut loose.
In a way, they're using his
goodness against him.
OK, let's unpack the context
here.
The why?
Why are they robbing Lady
Watcher?
Why this intense desperation?
Because the sources say they've
been on a serious losing streak
for the last five days.
Losing streak is a polite way to
put it.
I mean, it's been a catastrophe.
To understand the tension in
session 26, you have to look at
the tragedy of their friend
Tracidor.
Tracidor was their cleric,
right?
The healer he.
Was and we need to explain why
that matters so much.
In a land like Borovia or in
Dungeons and Dragons generally a
cleric is your lifeline.
The ultimate safety net.
It is.
They are the source of healing,
of restoration, of curing
diseases.
Losing your cleric is like
losing your oxygen tank while
you are scuba diving in a dark
cave.
You might be OK for a minute,
but the panic sets in
immediately.
And he didn't just die
peacefully in his sleep.
This was violent.
Far from it.
Tracidor was executed.
The party, to their credit,
retrieved his corpse.
Which couldn't have been easy.
No, they hauled his body all the
way to the Abbey of Saint
Markova, in a place called
Kresk.
They were banking everything on
a resurrection.
And this is the part of the
record that creeps me out.
They go to the Abbot, who agrees
to bring him back.
But there's a catch.
There's always a catch.
There is always a catch in
Barofia.
The Abbot is well, he's a deeply
disturbing figure.
He agrees to the resurrection,
but the price is a wedding
dress.
Wedding dress.
Yes, a wedding dress.
A wedding dress for his Gollum
bride.
He is building a flesh Gollum to
be a bride for someone and the
text heavily implies it's for
Strad and he needs a dress.
That is just horrifying.
It turns this holy mission of
saving their friend into this
grotesque, macabre errand.
Go find me a dress for my
monster and I'll fix your
friend.
Exactly.
It shows the lengths the party
was willing to go to.
They agreed to this bizarre
barter.
They went and got the dress.
But here is the kicker.
The miracle failed.
The resurrection didn't take.
Wait, how does a resurrection
fail?
I thought that was just a spell
you cast.
You paid the diamond, or in this
case, the dress, and poof, he's
back.
Usually yes, but Borovia is
different.
Souls are tracked there.
The dark powers that rule this
land don't like letting people
go, and they don't always let
them come back.
So it's like the whole realm is
working against them.
It is a failed resurrection
implies that Traxidor's soul
might not be free to return.
Or perhaps if the Abbot's power
is corrupted and not what it
seems, it shifts the genre from
high fantasy to cosmic horror.
The rules you thought you knew
don't apply here.
So they paid the price, they did
the horrible errand and got
nothing.
That's devastating.
And it gets worse.
Of course it does.
Shortly after that failure, they
are at a place called Salinka
Pass, which is this high
freezing mountain Rd.
They're trying to find the Amber
Temple, a place of dark secrets,
and they get jumped by rocks.
Rocks.
What are rocks?
Demonic vulture like creatures
screeching flying nightmares
with hooked beaks and claws.
In that encounter, Tracidor's
body is well, the text says he
is killed again.
His body is killed again.
How do you kill a corpse?
They tore it apart, mutilated it
beyond repair.
It's just adding insult to
injury.
It's the universe telling them
stop trying it.
Represents finality.
Total finality.
The party realizes they can't
save him.
There's nothing left to save.
They cremate what's left of him
in these mysterious green flames
of the past.
Green flames?
That sounds ominous.
Very.
It suggests magical fire,
perhaps linked to the dark
entities of the Amber Temple
they were seeking.
But the take away for the party
is that Tracidor is gone
permanently.
That's the nail in the coffin.
Literally.
When you cremate the body, you
are admitting we are never
fixing this.
That is a heavy psychological
break for a group of heroes.
And with him, the Amulet of
Ravenkind was lost.
That's the connection.
Right.
It had been taken from him
earlier when Tracidor was
captured by Lady Walker's
forces.
So that is the connection.
They need the amulet because
without their cleric, without
their healer, they are terrified
of facing the big bad straw.
So they feel naked with that is
their only crutch left.
Exactly, they believe this
amulet is the only thing that
levels the playing field.
It can create sunlight.
It hurts vampires.
It's not just a heist for greed,
it's a heist for survival.
They are acting out of pure
fear.
Now I want to talk about the
journey itself because the
outline mentions this stuff
happened.
It's like a pass.
But the heist is in Valachi.
That's not next door, is it?
No, it's a significant trek and
I think that travel time is
crucial.
Imagine walking down a cold
mountain, carrying the ashes of
your friend in a pouch, knowing
you failed him.
Just silence and grief.
Right.
That silence, that travel time,
that is where the desperation
festers.
By the time they get back to
civilization, they aren't
thinking clearly.
They're desperate for any kind
of win.
Which brings us to the deception
of Bismarck.
They pick him up in the village
of Barovia on their way to
Vilagi, and this is where the
morality of the group really
starts to look Gray.
Dark Gray they recruit is Mark
now is Mark is motivated by one
thing and one thing only, his
adopted sister Irena.
Right.
And the party knows where Irena
is.
They have first hand knowledge.
They do.
They know that during a previous
vampire attack on Valaki, she
was taken.
She is with Strad at Castle
Ravenloft.
She is, for all intents and
purposes, gone.
But they don't tell Liz Mark
that.
No, they tell him.
Come with us to Valaki.
We're going to fight vampires.
Your sister is there.
It is a lie by omission.
Weaponized to recruit him as
extra muscle.
OK, I'm.
Going to play devil's advocate
here for a second.
Is it actually that cold or is
it the only play they have?
If they don't get the amulet,
they can't kill Straud.
If they can't kill Straud, Irena
is doomed anyway right?
Isn't lying to is Mark actually
the most moral thing to do to
save the world?
Like utilitarian ethics, The
needs of the many.
That is certainly the argument
the party would make themselves
to sleep at night.
The ends justify the means.
But think about the human cost
of that.
You are manipulating a man's
love for his family to use him
as a meat shield.
There's a harsh way to put it.
But it's true, yes,
strategically it makes a certain
kind of cold sense, but morally
it's corrosive.
It turns an ally into a tool.
You're not partners anymore,
you're a user and he's the used.
And it creates this incredible
dramatic irony for us, the
readers.
We know the truth.
The party knows the truth.
But is Mark is fighting with the
fury of a brother trying to save
his family, completely unaware
that he is fighting for a lost
cause?
And that tension is going to
snap.
It has to.
You can't maintain a lie that
big under that much pressure.
So, armed with this lie and
their desperation, they arrive
at Valaki.
Now, Valaki is a walled town.
You can't just waltz in,
especially if you've caused
trouble there before, which they
have.
Right, so they don't knock on
the front door, they breach the
walls and go straight for Lady
Watchers house.
They opt for a subterranean
entry, the root cellar.
Classic high strobe.
Start from the bottom and work
your way up.
And almost immediately, they
find something that suggests
Lady Walker isn't just a rich
noblewoman who likes nice tea
and political maneuvering.
They find a secret chamber with
a pentagram on the floor.
Yeah, nothing good ever happens
in a room with a pentagram on
the floor.
Never.
What does that tell them?
What does that signal to the
party?
It's strongly implies devil
worship or summoning rituals.
It completely changes the
context of the heist.
They aren't just robbing a
political rival, they are
stepping into a cultist Slayer.
The air probably smells like
sulfur and old blood.
It signals to the party the
rules of engagement have
changed.
You are dealing with infernal
powers.
But they don't find the amulet
there.
So your horn.
The Beastmaster decides to use
magic.
He casts Locate object.
A smart move.
Why search physically when you
can search magically?
It's like having a GPS for
treasure.
It should be simple.
And the result.
Silence the spell.
Fails.
It does not detect the Amulet of
Ravenkind.
OK I want to dig into this
mechanic cuz this is a crucial
moment.
When you say the skull fails,
does that mean the amulet
absolutely isn't there or is
there wiggle room?
There is a little wiggle room
and that is what the party
latches onto in this magic
system.
There is one specific material
that blocks divination spells,
like this one lead.
Lead like the metal.
Yes, a thin sheet of lead is
like kryptonite for locate
object.
If the amulet is inside a lead
lined box, the magic just
bounces off.
The spell would say I can't find
it even if it's three feet away
from you.
So they convince themselves it's
hidden, not missing.
They create an explanation that
fits their desired outcome.
Exactly.
A rational actor might say the
spell failed, let's cut our
losses and leave.
But this goes back to the sunk
cost fallacy we were talking
about.
They have traveled all this way.
They have lied to Ismark.
They have breached at the town
walls.
They cannot accept that it might
be for nothing.
They needed to be there.
They needed to be there, so they
manufacture a reason to stay.
Oh, I must be in a lead box
upstairs.
So they ignore the massive red
flag.
They leave the cellar and head
up.
And this is where the heist
portion of the evening falls
apart completely.
They move from the cellar to the
mud room.
Dermont, the rogue cracks open a
door.
This should be his moment.
He's the Arcane Trickster.
This is his entire job
description.
He sees a guard posted at the
back door.
The setup is perfect for a
stealth takedown.
Slip in silence.
The guard keep moving.
The plan is still alive.
He draws his rapier, he leaps
out, and then physics happens.
The source material notes that
the narrow confines thwart the
attack.
I want you to imagine a
cluttered hallway full of boots
and coats and stacked firewood.
He lunges, but his blade catches
on the Stonewall.
I can hear that sound, that
horrible scree of metal on
stone.
It's the loudest sound in the
world in that moment.
It completely ruins the element
of surprise.
The sentry ducks, and more
importantly, he starts yelling.
The alarm is raised.
The stealth run is over.
Enter Radley.
Radley solves the problem the
only way an Eldritch Knight
knows how.
He steps in and, to quote the
record, hammers the sentry to
death.
Brutal.
No subtlety there.
It is effective, but it is loud
and messy.
The guard dies in a pool of
blood.
The tone of the mission shifts
instantly.
We are no longer watching
Ocean's 11.
We are watching The Texas
Chainsaw Massacre.
And noise travels.
The yelling, the hammering, the
whole house is waking up.
The dominoes start falling.
They hear footsteps upstairs.
They rush into a storeroom to
hide, trying to regain some
control.
A storeroom full of common
supplies.
Not exactly a fortress.
They're crouching behind bags of
flour and crates of wine.
And while they are in there
hiding, debating whether to
barricade themselves in, a
servant woman walks in.
Talk about bad timing.
Just absolutely the worst luck.
She's probably just coming to
get a broom or something.
Imagine her perspective for a
second.
She opens the door to get a mop,
and she finds a group of heavily
armed, blood splattered
adventurers hiding among the
crates, her world just turned
upside down.
And they tell her to run.
Which she does, but she also
screams.
Actually, if I saw Radley
standing there with a hammer
dripping blood, I'd scream too.
I'd scream my lungs out.
Her screams alert the guards in
the front foyer.
Now the house is fully,
completely awake.
The party dispatches those
guards again.
Seasoned adventurers versus
common men at arms is a
mismatch, but the chaos is
uncontrolled now.
There's no plan anymore.
It's a cascade of failure, one
mistake after another.
Screaming, servants, dying
guards, blood on the floor, and
they just keep pushing forward.
They rush through the kitchen,
into the foyer, and finally into
the parlor.
They are rushing toward the
center of the house, ignoring
the sounds of people putting on
armor upstairs.
They are committed to this
aggressive, headlong push.
Let's talk about the parlor,
because the source gives us some
great visual details here.
It's not a dungeon, it's a home.
This is someone's space.
It's opulent.
You have velvet couches, a
roaring hearth, a crystal
chandelier catching the light.
It's a scene of domestic wealth
and a portrait above the
fireplace.
The portrait of a distinguished
man with a broken nose.
It's such a specific detail, I
love it.
It tells you about the family.
They're wealthy, but they're
rough.
Maybe former adventurers
themselves, or just a family
that seen its share of brawls.
It grounds the scene.
This isn't a generic video game
level.
It's someone's living room
that's about to be turned into a
war zone.
But the party doesn't have time
to admire the art.
They have arrived at the boss
fight.
Lady Watcher.
She's been the antagonist in the
background for a while.
What is she doing?
Is she surprised?
She is there, but she isn't
alone.
She's prepared.
She has two wardens with her,
and these aren't just guards,
they are spellcasters.
They are using necromantic bolts
and summoning spiritual weapons.
So the difficulty curve just
spiked massively.
We go from common guards to
magic users.
And Lady Wacker is smart.
She's not a fool.
She realizes she is outnumbered.
The party, despite the botched
stealth, is a formidable combat
unit.
So she escalates.
How does she escalate?
She summons a devil.
Because of course she does.
The pentagram in the basement
wasn't just for decoration.
She pulls a creature straight
from the 9 Hells right into her
parlor.
It just appears in a flash of
smoke and brimstone.
I love the description of
Bismarck here, The source says.
He lets out a cry of despair.
Think about that for a second.
Bismarck is a guy who deals with
wolves and maybe the occasional
zombie.
He's a grounded mortal fighter.
He thinks he is here to fight
vampires.
Suddenly space and reality tear
open and a barbed devil steps
out.
The cognitive dissonance must be
overwhelming.
He has no frame of reference for
this.
None.
He's looking at this thing
thinking, What have you people
got me into?
But he fights.
To his credit, he doesn't break.
He fights Radley, engages the
devil.
Now Radley is a fire user.
Typically that's his go to
magic, but he knows or figures
out very quickly that fire
doesn't hurt devils.
They live in hell.
Right.
They're used to the heat, so he
has to go toe to toe with steel
is Mark joins him.
They are in the trenches, right
there on the expensive rug,
fighting this thing from another
plane of existence.
Meanwhile, your horn is getting
creative.
He's using the environment.
I really enjoyed this tactical
detail.
Your horn is 1/2, so he is
small, maybe 3 feet tall.
He's riding his great cat.
He has his cat leap onto the
dining table.
Just scattering the fine China.
Scattering fine silver and
crystal with a crash, the record
says.
Imagine the noise.
He takes the high ground and
it's the crockery to fire
arrows.
It's a chaotic, cinematic image.
It's pure desperation using the
furniture as terrain because
you're out of options.
And Dearman the rogue, the one
who started all this, He's
having a rough time.
Lehrman is dealing with the
invisible threat.
He tries to get to Lady Water,
but he just hears these wings.
The buzzing of a giant fly.
An imp, but an invisible one.
It attacks them from behind.
Lady Water.
It stings him.
And Imps are poisonous, right?
Highly.
The puncture itself is small,
almost like a pinprick, but the
poison causes intense pain and
serious damage.
It's terrifying because he can't
see what's hurting him.
He just feels the pain, hears
the buzzing wings, and knows
something is hunting him.
That breeds paranoia in a fight.
So you've got a devil fighting
the fighter and the Burgamaster
on the floor.
You've got a halfling on the
dining table destroying the
dinnerware.
You've got a rogue getting stung
by an invisible monster and
Pearland.
Pearland the Monk is just a
whirlwind of martial artistry,
attacking multiple foes, trying
to control the chaos.
And amazingly, the party
actually starts to gain the
upper hand.
They kill the devil.
They take down the wardens.
They are winning after all the
mistakes, they are going to pull
this off.
That is what they think.
For one brief, shining moment,
it looks like they've turned the
tide.
They are on the brink of
capturing Lady Water.
But this is Dungeons and
Dragons.
The tide can turn on a single
spell.
And Lady Watcher has one big
card left to play.
Spirit Guardians.
Oh, that is a nasty spell.
For the uninitiated, explain
what Spirit Guardians does.
Break it down.
Think of it as a magical
blender.
The caster calls forth spirits.
In Lady Waffer's case, the text
implies they look like spectral
devils or tortured souls.
These spirits swirl around her
in a 15 foot radius.
Any enemy that starts their turn
there or even enters the area
gets shredded by these phantoms.
It's constant grinding holy, or
in this case, unholy damaged.
So it's area denial.
Don't come near me.
It is.
And because the party has closed
in to capture her, they've all
rushed her.
They're literally getting within
arm's reach.
They are all in the kill zone.
The source says this spell
breaks the party.
Instantly.
It's not a slow attrition,
you're a horn.
The beastmaster on the table
drops unconscious her lane.
The monk, in the middle of his
flurry of blows, drops
unconscious.
Half the party is down in the
blink of an eye.
The blender turned on and they
got caught in the blades.
And your horn's cat, his loyal
companion.
It flees.
The bond is strong, but the
survival instinct is stronger.
The cat sees its master go down,
feels this aura of death, and it
runs.
That's a sign of how bad things
have gotten.
The loyal pet abandons the
master.
So now it's just Radley and his
mark standing.
The two half wings are on the
floor dying.
Lady Watcher is gloating.
She's probably laughing
maniacally.
Maniacal Glee is the phrase used
in the record.
She is calling for them to be
killed.
She has won.
The trap has been sprung.
This is the moment where the
mission shifts.
It's no longer robbery, it's
rescue.
Radley and Ismark have to switch
rules completely.
They become medics and porters.
They grab the unconscious
halflings.
They can't fight anymore.
If they stay to fight, everyone
dies.
There's no victory here.
None.
Radley grabs a body, Ismark
grabs a body and they run.
And as they run, Radley makes a
choice that I think defines his
character in this moment.
A very telling action.
The scorched earth policy.
Describe what he does.
On the way out, carrying his
fallen comrade, passing that
storeroom full of supplies, the
flour, the oil, the wine, he
casts fire bolt.
He sets the house on fire.
Ostensibly, you could argue it's
a tactical decision to delay
pursuit.
Smoke and fire create confusion.
It covers their escape.
But it's more than that, isn't
it?
Oh yeah, let's be honest, it's
also an act of pure spite.
It feels like a tantrum.
If we can't have the amulet, you
don't get to have a house.
It's ruthless and it transforms
them from adventurers into
arsonists.
They aren't just thieves
anymore, they are destroyers.
They've crossed a line.
Pearland wakes up while being
carried.
Monks are resilient, but
Yurihorn is out cold.
They flee over the town walls,
avoiding the gates entirely.
Because the gates would be
guarded.
Now the alarm is raised, the
whole town is waking up.
Going over the wall is the only
way.
They made it to the tree line.
They are safe physically, but
emotionally, this is where the
real explosion happens.
The confrontation with is Mark.
It was inevitable.
This is always going to happen.
Paint the picture for us there
in the woods.
It's dark.
They're catching their breath.
Smoke is rising from the town
behind them.
Ismark is agitated.
He is looking at that smoke.
He's looking at his allies who
just nearly got him killed by a
devil.
He's covered in blood and dirt
and he says we have to go back,
we have to save Irena.
And the party?
Yeah, they can't keep the lie up
anymore.
They're too tired.
The facade crumbles.
They are beaten, the adrenaline
is fading, replaced by
exhaustion and failure.
They finally tell him the truth.
Irena isn't there is Mark.
She was taken days ago.
Straud has her.
Imagine being is Mark in that
moment.
The betrayal must feel absolute.
It's profound.
The source describes his
reaction as incredulous.
He swears.
He looks toward the mountains,
toward Castle Raven loft.
In the distance.
He realizes he has been played.
Everything he just went through
was for nothing.
He's furious.
He rebukes them.
He was used as a meat shield for
a heist that had nothing to do
with his sister.
And how does the party defend
themselves?
Do they apologize?
Do they show any remorse or beg
for forgiveness?
I bet they don't based on their
actions so far.
No, no, they are unapologetic.
Their defense is purely
pragmatic, they tell him.
We cannot fight straw without
the amulet.
We did this for the greater
good.
We lied to you because we need
this item to win.
Your feelings don't matter right
now.
It's a cold calculus.
They are telling him that his
feelings and even his sister's
immediate safety, are secondary
to the strategic necessity of
the amulet.
We used you because we had to.
Does his mark accept that?
How does he even process that?
The text says he is placated for
the moment, but falls into a
brooding silence.
That trust is shattered.
It's not broken, it's gone.
He might still travel with them
because he has no other choice,
but the relationship has
fundamentally changed forever.
He stuck with them.
He can't storm Castle Raven Loft
alone.
He needs them, even if he hates
them right now.
Precisely.
It's a forced alliance now, a
marriage of convenience held
together only by mutual hatred
of Strad.
So battered, bruised and morally
compromised, they trek to the
Wizards of wine.
The winery is their last safe
haven in the area.
It's a long, silent walk in the
dark.
And when they get there, your
horn finally wakes up.
It was the first thing he does.
He didn't ask what happened.
He doesn't check his wounds.
He's paranoid.
He immediately uses his primeval
awareness.
He's checking for the imp.
That invisible attacker left a
psychological scar.
He reaches out with his senses
to see if that fiend, that
little devil, is following them.
He needs to know if they are
truly safe or if the hunt is
still on.
Are they safe?
No sense of the imp.
They are safe for now.
Man, what a session.
So let's zoom out.
We've gone through the play by
play.
What does this all mean?
Well, if we look at the mission
of this deep dive, which was to
analyze the party's decision
making, the verdict is just it's
damning.
This session is a textbook
example of the sunk cost fallacy
leading to utter disaster.
Break that down for the
listeners.
What is the sunk cost fallacy
really in this context?
Think of it like gambling.
Imagine you at a blackjack table
and you've lost your rent money.
The smart play is to walk away,
but you keep betting.
Not because you think you'll
win, but because walking away
means admitting you ruined
everything.
You're trying to win back what
you already lost, so you keep
making bad bets.
So the party kept betting.
Exactly.
They started with a bad hand, No
cleric, the trauma of Tracidor's
final death.
They tried to fix it with a
heist.
When the heist showed clear
signs of failure, the located
object spell finding nothing,
they doubled down because they
had already spent the effort of
getting there.
And crucially, the moral cost of
lying to is Mark.
They didn't want to walk away
empty handed, so they walked
away almost dead.
And empty handed.
Anyway, that's the tragic part.
They didn't get the amulet.
The net result of this entire
session is negative.
They lost resources, they lost
health, they completely
destroyed the relationship with
is Mark, and they burned down a
house in a town they might need
to visit again.
And they lost their reputation.
I mean, let's be blunt, they are
arsonists and liars now.
The moral decay is the other key
take away here.
The darkening tone of the
narrative is palpable.
To survive in Borovia, the
heroes are becoming less heroic.
They are adopting the
ruthlessness of the very land
they're trying to save.
It's that old Nietzsche saying
he who fights monsters should
see to it that he himself does
not become a monster.
It applies perfectly here.
By engaging with Lady Watcher on
her terms, by lying to is Mark,
by using fire and brute force,
they are sliding down a very
slippery slope.
They're starting to look a lot
like the villains.
And the loss of tracidor is
still haunting them.
It feels like the root of all
this.
It's the vacuum that is Mark
cannot fill is Mark is a
warrior.
He's a leader in his own right,
but he is not a cleric.
He cannot heal the parties
wounds or their souls.
The party is grieving, even if
they aren't admitting it, and
that grief is driving them to
make rash emotional decisions.
They're acting out of trauma.
So here is where it gets really
interesting for you, the
listener, to think about.
Consider the position they are
in now.
They are at the Wizards of Wine,
they're hiding, Stride has
Irina, the amulet is missing,
and for all they know was never
even in that house is Mark
dressed them about as far as he
can throw.
Them the walls are closing in.
Every option they had is now
worse than it was before.
Here's my final provocative
thought for you to chew on.
The party burned their bridges
in Valaki, literally with that
fire bolt, and they alienated
the burgomaster of the village
of Barovia.
They did all of this to get
stronger to get the amulet, but
by trying so desperately to get
this one item, have they
actually made themselves more
vulnerable?
It's a paradox, isn't it?
In their quest for strength,
they have stripped away their
allies and their safe harbors.
They are alone in the woods, now
more than ever.
They have traded social capital
and their moral high ground for
a lottery ticket that didn't pay
out.
A sobering thought.
They survived the session, but
can they survive the campaign?
Only time will tell, but they
need to start checking for
traps, both the physical ones
and more importantly, the
psychological ones that keep
setting for themselves.
That's all for this deep dive
into session 26.
Thanks for listening.
And remember, if the magic
detector says the treasure isn't
there, maybe just believe it.
And watch out for the Today.
We are dissecting the anatomy of
a disaster.
Session 26 wasn't just a failed
mission, it was a master class
and how desperation forces good
people to make some terrible,
arguably catastrophic choices.
We are looking at a party of
adventurers who are battered,
bereft of their cleric, and
while currently hiding in the
mud at the Wizards of Wine.
It's a dark chapter, for sure.
We've gone from the tragic,
really visceral death of
Traxxador at the Telenka Pass to
a chaotic, botched infiltration
of Lady Walker's home in Valaki.
But let's be clear right out of
the gate, We aren't just here to
critique their stealth roles or,
you know, their combat spacing.
We are here to talk about the
lie.
Right, it's the lie.
Capital T, Capital L The
decision to manipulate their
ally is Mark by withholding the
devastating truth about his
sister Irena.
They used him as a well as a
battering ram for a heist while
he thought he was fighting a
noble war to protect her.
The central question we really
have to answer is was this a
necessary act of survival, a
pragmatic play to keep the
campaign alive, or was it a
moral failure that has
permanently fractured the party?
Right.
It's the classic conflict, the
mission versus the people.
On one side you have the cold
logic of we need the artifact to
kill the vampire.
On the other, you have the
absolute erosion of trust, and
looking at the state of the
party right now, I'd say the
cost was way too high.
And I am going to argue that the
deception was a strategic
necessity.
I mean, look at the board.
Traxador is dead.
The Amulet of Ravenkind is
missing.
The party was cornered.
Utilizing Ismark was the only
path to survive that encounter
and keep the campaign against
Stroth on the rails.
While I'm arguing that the
foundation of this mission was
rotten from minute 1, treating a
sovereign ally like a pawn led
to a chaotic retreat, 0 material
gain, and a volatile breach of
trust that endangers everyone.
I mean they traded a friend for
a chance at loot and they ended
up with neither.
OK, let's start by setting the
stage, because I don't think you
can judge this decision in a
vacuum.
You have to look at the
psychological state of the
party.
They didn't just lose Traxador.
This wasn't a standard combat
death where you, you know,
revivify the cleric and move on.
They watched him get torn apart
by rocks at the Desolinka Pass.
It was brutal.
The description of that death
was heavy.
It was visceral.
And then the aftermath.
They drag his body to the
gatehouse, the plan to trade the
wedding dress to the Abbot for a
resurrection that failed.
They had no way to bring him
back, so they end up at the
gatehouse, burning their
friend's body in those
mysterious magical green flames
just to prevent him from rising
as an undead spawn of Strawd.
That scene just sets the tone
for everything that follows.
Standing there, watching the
green fire consume your cleric,
the smell of ozone and burning
flesh, I mean, that changes a
group.
It hollows you out.
It makes you realize that the
safety net is gone.
Exactly.
They are exhausted, they are
traumatized, and they are
terrified.
Their primary goal is defeating
Straud.
That is the objective reality.
To do that, they believe they
need the Amulet of Ravenkind,
and they have Intel.
Flawed Intel, maybe, but Intel
nonetheless That it's in Lady
Walker's possession.
So they limp back to Valaki.
Right.
And who do they find is Mark?
And he is frantic.
He knows vampires attacked the
church.
He knows his sister was there.
Now put yourself in the party's
shoes.
If they tell him the truth right
then that Irena was taken by the
mob and hand delivered to
Straud, what happens?
He reacts emotionally, sure.
He's her brother.
He's the lesser.
Emotionally is a massive
understatement.
He spirals.
He launches a suicide mission
directly at Castle Ravenloft.
He marches to the drawbridge and
demands his sister back, and
Straud peels him apart like an
orange.
The party loses an ally and they
probably die trying to save him.
So the logic is we have to lie
to him to save him from himself.
It's a benevolent deception.
By telling him they were going
to Valaki to stop Lady Walker,
they channeled his rage into a
target they actually needed to
hit.
They needed his sword.
They needed his body in the
room.
It kept him alive and it gave
them a shot at the artifact that
saves everyone, including Irina.
It was the only logical path.
See, you call it benevolent.
I call it arrogant.
You're assuming the party knows
what's best for is Mark better
than is Mark does, and that
arrogance led to a catastrophic
miscalculation.
You're arguing the ends justify
the means, but look at the ends.
The heist was a total failure.
The outcome doesn't invalidate
the strategy.
Sometimes you make the right
play and the dice just don't go
your way.
That's that's just the game.
But the strategy relied on a lie
that blew up in their faces.
Look at the facts.
They break into the root cellar.
Yuri Horn casts locate object.
Result.
Nothing.
Silence.
They get to the secret chamber
with the pentagram empty.
They dragged Izmark into a
devil's den based on a hunch.
They recruited him under false
pretenses.
I mean he thought he was
fighting for justice but he was
actually just a meat shield for
a loot run.
A loot run for a holy artifact
that creates sunlight?
You're minimizing the stakes to
make them sound like common
burglars.
And you're minimizing the cost
of trust.
They created an internal enemy.
When the truth finally came out
in the tree line, Izmark wasn't
just upset, he was incredulous.
He realized he had been played.
You have traded long term
loyalty for a short term gain
that didn't even pay off.
They are now hiding at the
winery with the silent brooding
man who knows his friends will
lie to his face if it served
their agenda.
That isn't strategy, that is
self sabotage.
I disagree that it's self
sabotage, I think it's damage
control.
But let's let's move into the
core debate and dissect the
actual events of the heist.
I want to talk about the
execution because you claim the
lie caused the chaos.
I argue the chaos was inevitable
and the party handled it with
remarkable prowess because they
had his mark.
Prowess.
Are we watching the same
session?
The operation was sloppy from
the moment they left the
basement.
It was a high risk entry, high
risk, high reward.
It was a botched entry.
Let's just look at the tape.
Dare men, Their rogue cracks
open the door to the mud room.
He has the element of surprise.
This is what rogues do.
This is his bread and butter.
And what happens?
He leaps in his rapier, scrapes
the Stonewall skirt, and the
guard ducks.
That's a critical failure in
stealth execution.
Well, that's the friction of
combat even the best rogues
miss.
You can't plan for a bad die
roll.
But you can plan for the
consequences.
Because the party was so
disjointed, the reaction was
just panic.
The guard yells.
The alarm is raised instantly.
Then they scramble to the
kitchen.
They find a servant.
Instead of managing that
situation, you know, subduing
her, intimidating her, casting
silence, she screams and flees.
Within seconds, the entire house
is alert.
This wasn't a tactical strike.
It was a loud, clumsy home
invasion.
If they had been honest with
Ismarc, perhaps they could have
formulated A cohesive assault
plan rather than this piece meal
room to room panic.
I don't buy that for a second.
The trap was waiting for them,
regardless of how quietly they
knocked or how honest they were
with the NPC.
Lady Voctor didn't just have
guards, she had wardens.
We're talking spellcasters
capable of high level
necromancy.
She had the ability to summon a
barbed devil.
This wasn't a situation that
could be solved with a perfect
sneak attack.
You really think is Mark's
presence changed the math that
much?
It saved the campaign.
Look at the data.
Radley hammered that guard in
the mud room to death instantly.
That was good focus fire.
But when the devil was summoned,
who was there Is Mark?
Is Mark was there shouting in
despair because he didn't
understand what was happening.
He's fighting a devil while
thinking he's there to stop a
political rival.
But he engaged.
That is the point.
Radley and is Mark bravely
engaged, a literal fiend from
the Hells.
Radley knew his fire bolt was
useless against the devil's
resistance, so he went in with
steel.
But is Mark?
Is Mark tanked the damage he
stood in the paint without is
Mark absorbing those blows that
devil would have been tearing
into your horn or purlin much
earlier.
Without the lie that brought is
Mark to that room, the party
suffers a total party kill.
Period.
That is a strong claim.
You think they wipe without him?
Absolutely.
Look at the damage output.
The party was split, half of
them were getting chewed up
upstairs without his mark
holding the line downstairs.
The pincer movement crushes
them, the devil comes up the
stairs, the wardens come down,
and the campaign ends in session
26.
OK, I'll grant you that his mark
was a useful meat shield, but
that brings me to the second
point, the cost of engagement.
You're framing this as a
survival story.
They didn't die, but I see a
list of casualties that suggests
the party is operating way
beyond its capacity.
They are alive.
That is the only metric that
matters in Borovia.
Barely.
Look at the physical toll.
Let's talk about Spirit
guardians.
Lady walked her signature spell.
Nasty piece of work.
It was devastating.
Listeners need to understand the
mechanics here.
Spirit Guardians isn't just
damage, it creates difficult
terrain.
It halves your movement speed.
So you have Orihorn in Pearland
running up the stairs trying to
close the gap and they are
suddenly wading through spectral
devils that are tearing their
souls apart.
They can't move fast enough to
get out of the radius.
They took a beating, I admit.
A beating.
They were shredded.
Orihorn and Pearland were both
rendered unconscious.
That is, two party members down
in rounds.
And look at the psychological
toll.
Orihorn's cat fled the scene.
The Beastmaster bond, Yeah.
Exactly, that bond is
supernatural for the animal to
panic and run ignoring its
masters command.
The level of fear and necrotic
energy in that room must have
been off the charts.
And don't forget Dharman, he was
poisoned by an invisible imp.
A superficial puncture, yes, but
do they have antitoxin?
Do they have a lesser
restoration spell prepared now
that tracks the doors Ash?
No, they're broken.
And yet they retreated
successfully.
That is a tactical win.
In a worst case scenario, you're
focusing on the damage taken,
I'm focusing on the extraction.
Extraction.
They ran away.
Radley had the presence of mind
despite the chaos, despite the
devil clong at him to cast fire
bolts into the storeroom.
He created a smokescreen, A
distraction to delay pursuit.
That is veteran thinking.
They didn't leave anyone behind.
Radley and Ismark carried the
fallen bodies out.
Perlin, to his credit, regained
consciousness and walked, but
Radley carried Yurihorn all the
way out.
That shows unit cohesion.
It shows desperation.
They ran between houses like
rats.
They dropped Yurihorn in the
dirt to bind his bleeding
wounds.
They didn't even dare go for the
main gates.
They had to scramble over the
wall to escape to the Wizards of
Wine.
They are now battered.
Yuri Horn's cat is prowling
nervously and they have nothing
to show for it.
No amulet, no dead lady walked
her, just injuries, A poisoned
rogue and a furious ally.
They have intelligence.
They know what Lady Walker is
capable of now.
They know the amulet isn't
easily found.
And they have lost the moral
high ground.
Which leads us to the most
critical point, the revelation,
the scene in the tree line
outside the walls.
This is where the pragmatic
argument just crumbles for me.
I think it holds up perfectly.
Picture the scene, they are
outside the walls patching
wounds Is Mark is agitated,
rightfully so.
He wants to go back in.
He's talking about saving Arena
from the chaos of Valaki.
He thinks she's still in the
town.
The party finally tells him the
truth.
She isn't in Valaki.
She was taken by the mob and
given distraught.
And you think this was the right
time to tell him while he's
wiping Devil Icker off his
blade?
It was the only time they
couldn't hide it anymore.
If they let him run back into
Valaki, he dies to the guards of
the vampires.
They needed to stop him from
running into a slaughterhouse.
They told him because they were
cornered, not because they
respected him.
And look at his reaction.
The session notes are specific.
Ismark wasn't just mad.
He was incredulous.
He swears in frustration.
He rebukes them.
This isn't just a disagreement
on tactics.
He feels betrayed.
He demands they go to Castle
Wavenloft immediately.
And the party stood their ground
with logic.
This is why I respect their
play.
They didn't cave to his emotion,
they told him unapologetically.
We cannot confront Straud
without the Amulet of Ravenkind.
This is an objective fact.
They believe this artifact is
the key to creating sunlight,
which is the only thing that
evens the odds against the
vampire Lord is.
Mark's anger is emotional.
The party stands as strategic.
Strategic.
They sound like cold blooded
manipulators.
Sorry we lied to you about your
sister being kidnapped by a
monster, but we really needed
you to tank that devil for us.
Now sit down and shut up.
But it worked.
They placated him.
He fell into a brooding silence.
That silence means he is still
following them.
He didn't attack them.
He didn't leave.
He went with them to the winery.
He went to the winery because he
has nowhere else to go.
But you aren't misreading that
silence.
Abroading silence is not
consent.
It is resentment stewing.
You have a powerful warrior who
now knows you view him as a
tool.
He knows you withheld the most
important information in his
life just to get him to swing a
sword.
He's still a resource they have
access to.
For how long?
Trust is a resource in this game
just as much as hit points or
spell slots.
The party spent all their trust
capital on this failed heist.
Izmark is a ticking time bomb.
What happens when they get close
to Ravenloft?
What happens when Straud offers
Izmark a deal?
Bring me the amulet and I'll let
you see her.
Izmark hates Straud.
He won't turn.
But he might hate the party now
too, or at least not trust them
to watch his back.
If he abandons them in a
critical moment or charges in
recklessly because he refuses to
listen to their plans anymore,
that creates A vulnerability
that the amulet, if they ever
find it, can't fix.
That's a risk, certainly, but
let's look at the alternative
again.
If they hadn't lied.
Is Mark runs to Ravenloft alone
and dies.
The party tries to take walked
her house alone and likely dies
to the Wardens.
And the devil without is Mark's
help.
The lie bought them another day.
It bought them a chance to rest
at the Wizards of Wine.
Your horn used primeval
awareness and confirmed the imp
wasn't pursuing them.
They're safe for the moment.
Safe but hollowed out.
They are resting.
Yes, Yuri Horn is conscious
again, but the dynamic has
shifted.
They are no longer heroes
leading a rebellion.
They are desperate survivors
manipulating their friends.
Sometimes in Borovia, that is
the only way to be a hero.
You have to make the hard calls.
They prioritize the mission over
feelings.
And in doing so, they may have
doomed the mission by rotting it
from the inside.
Let's move to our conclusion.
We are looking at a party in a
dire state.
Trxador is dead and cremated.
The Amulet of Ravenkind is still
missing.
The party is hiding at the
Wizards of Wine, licking their
wounds.
And the psychological state is
just as bad.
You have a poisoned rogue.
Dermont is tough, but poison is
insidious.
You have a humiliated
Beastmaster whose cat is
nervous, which is a terrible
sign, and you have an ally in
Ismark who is silent, angry and
watching them with suspicious
eyes.
Despite all that, I maintain
that the party made the
necessary choices.
The world of Barovia is
unforgiving.
They attempted A decapitation
strike on Lady Walker to
retrieve a vital artifact.
It failed, yes, but the logic
behind utilizing Ismark was
sound.
They needed his strength to
survive and the evidence of the
battle.
The devil, the Spirit Guardians,
proves they would not have
walked out of there without him.
They preserved their lives to
fight another day.
But at what price?
I conclude that the party has
traded their moral compass for
survival, and it wasn't a good
trade.
They failed to get the item,
they failed to kill the target,
and they succeeded only in
alienating one of the few
powerful allies they have left.
By treating is Mark as a pawn,
they have sown seeds of distrust
that will likely blossom at the
worst possible moment, perhaps
at the gates of Ravenloft
itself.
That remains to be seen, but
what is clear is that the
tension between is Mark and the
party is now the most volatile
element in this campaign.
They are together at the winery,
but they are not united.
And that lack of unity is
exactly what Strat exploits.
A fascinating point to end on.
Thank you for joining us on the
debate.
Today.
We're looking at session 26AD
and D narrative covering a
heist, a devil fight, and a
pretty intense character
revelation.
Yeah, a really interesting piece
to dive into.
So let's jump right in.
A key theme I saw here was this
challenge of pacing, and it
starts right away, the opening
sequence in the root cellar.
It really slows the narrative
momentum without a payoff.
It weakens the hook.
It really does.
It's it's what I'd call a false
start.
A false.
Start.
OK, yeah, because functionally
it's accurate to the game,
right?
The players check a room, find
nothing.
A spell fails, but narratively
it just deflates all the
tension.
It feels like a list.
Exactly a list of procedural
checks.
You're primed for this exciting
heist, but the first paragraph
is just a description of things
not happening.
Right.
It's a log book, not a story.
So how do we strengthen that?
What's the alternative to just,
you know, reporting the failure?
Well, the suggestion is to use
this idea of failing forward.
If a scene has no loot and no
combat, it absolutely has to
have atmosphere or lore that
raises the stakes for what's
coming next.
You have to take the nothing
they found and make it an
ominous nothing.
I like that.
So not just emptiness, but a
threatening emptiness.
Can you give us a concrete
example with that pentagram?
Sure, so the text says they find
the pentagram, but finding
nothing else, they prepare to
ascend.
Right, a missed opportunity.
A huge 1.
Instead of just saying finding
nothing else, you could describe
the dust on the floor.
Maybe it's recently been
disturbed, implying the amulet
was moved just moments before
they got there.
Oh, that's good.
It changes the feeling from we
picked the wrong room which is
boring to we just missed them
which immediately ramps up the
urgency.
Turns a dead end into a near
miss and the spell failure that
felt very binary.
The spell does not detect it.
Yeah, exactly.
We can reframe that.
Instead of just saying the spell
failed, describe the sensation
of it failing.
Maybe the magic hits a a void, a
kind of suffocating magical
silence.
So it's not just a wasted spell
slot.
Not at all.
It becomes a narrative clue
about Lady Walker's power.
It tells the reader she's
prepared for this.
It's a villain reveal, not just
a mechanical failure.
And then just to tie it up, the
movement from the cellar to
upstairs.
Just condense it.
Combine the cellar and the
ascent into one fluid motion,
something like finding only a
chilling, empty pentagram below.
The party was forced upward
toward the sound of murmuring
voices.
It keeps things moving.
Excellent.
OK, moving on, let's talk about
that first fight, the skirmish
in the mud room.
The description relies a little
too heavily on mechanical
outcomes rather than the chaotic
reality of the space.
Right.
You have all these great details
mentioned, narrow confines,
household supplies, but they're
not really leveraged.
It's all a bit abrupt, isn't it?
From a botched stealth attempt
to a guard being hammered to
death.
Very abrupt.
It reads like a video game log.
Stealth failed, combat
initiated, enemy defeated.
We're missing the how?
I agree it moves too fast, so
the suggestion here is to lean
into the claustrophobia.
Use the clutter to make the
violence feel more desperate.
Exactly.
We need to know why the attack
failed in those confines, The
text says the rapier scrapes
along the wall.
Let's expand on that.
OK, describe it.
Getting tangled in a hanging
coat or hitting a door frame
with a loud clang show the
frustration of trying to use a
finesse weapon in a tiny,
cramped space.
It makes the failure feel
physical, not just like a bad
roll.
And that phrase hammered to
death.
It's intense, but.
It's abstract.
Let's make it visceral.
Use the environment.
Did Radley smash the guard
against the wall into the bench
and the noise?
Describe the sickening thud
against the wood.
That's why the alarm gets raised
so fast.
Violence is loud.
Right, you can't hide that
sound, which leads them to
hiding in the.
Storeroom, and this is a great
opportunity for contrast.
The text mentions common
household supplies.
Don't just list them, Juxtapose
those normal things, brooms,
sacks of flour, with these
bloodied adventurers hiding
among them.
That collision of the domestic
and the violent, that creates a
much stronger image.
It really highlights that the
party are the intruders here.
It grounds the scene, makes it
feel wrong, which is perfect for
a heist.
OK, let's get to the big set
piece, the climax and the
parlor.
The big fight.
The argument here is that it
lists the combatants well
enough, but it it misses an
opportunity to showcase the
specific horror of Lady Walker's
magic.
Yes, this is Ravenloft after
all.
It's supposed to be gothic
horror.
But the descriptions are very
functional.
Necromantic Bolts summons a
devil.
It's all very tactical.
It treats the devil like just
another monster with a block of
hit points, Not a terrifying
supernatural event.
There's no terror factor.
So the suggestion is to shift
focus from the tactical exchange
to the the psychological impact
of it all.
Precisely.
Let's start with the devil
summoning.
The text just says she summons a
devil.
That's it.
So dry it sounds like she's
ordering a cab.
Right.
So let's add that sensory
assault.
The smell of sulfur overpowering
old perfume, a sudden bone
chilling drop in temperature.
And is Mark's reaction, his cry
of despair.
That's not just a sound, that's
the reaction of a brave man
seeing a literal fiend from the
Hells.
That anchors the horror for the
reader.
It really does.
If he's terrified, we understand
the stakes.
OK, and what about the Spirit
Guardians?
The text says they're spectral
devils that tear and stab.
That's a decent start, but we
can push it.
Expand on that.
Are they screaming faces
grasping translucent claws?
And when they take down Yuri,
Horn and Purlon make it feel
visceral.
Not just hitting zero hit
points.
No, they're being overwhelmed by
spectral torment dragged down
Into Darkness.
It raises the stakes from we
need a healing potion to our
souls are under attack.
I see it really changes the
flavor.
And what about the Imp?
There's that great little detail
in there.
Oh I love this bit.
He gets stung and the text says
he still hears the flapping of
its wings.
Yeah, that's brilliant.
So make that the focus.
Focus on the invisibility, the
paranoia it creates.
He's poisoned, he's hurt, he
can't see his attacker, but he
can hear it.
That's pure horror.
Describe him swinging at empty
air, flinching at every sound.
It puts the reader right inside
his head.
It adds that psychological
stress to the physical damage.
OK, let's move to our final and
maybe most critical point, the
aftermath with his mark.
The big reveal, right?
And the issue is that this huge
emotional climax telling Ismark
the truth about his sister is
summarized so heavily it just
robs the scene of its dramatic
weight.
It really does.
This is arguably the most
important character moment of
the entire campaign so far.
They lied to him and the
narrative just says the party
finally tells him the truth.
It's like we're watching the
scene through a telescope.
Yeah, we're fast forwarding
through the best part of the
movie.
So the feedback is clear.
Slow down, use dialogue, use
body language.
Show us the trust breaking.
We need to zoom in.
It's that classic.
Show, don't tell, the text says
is.
Mark is incredulous.
That's an internal state.
How do we see that?
Give us some examples.
How do you show Incredulous
physically?
OK, well instead of just saying
it, describe him physically
stopping what he's doing.
He's binding Urehorn's wounds,
right?
A teammate, right?
The moment the truth comes out,
his hands should just stop.
He pulls away.
Describe the heavy silence that
falls over the group before they
confess.
And the rebuke, The text says he
rebukes them.
It sounds almost administrative.
It does.
We need to give his anger
specific weight.
Does he threaten to leave them?
Does he look at Radley, who's
holding the wounded or a horn
with just utter disgust?
We need to feel the heat of that
moment.
And then they try to placate him
with the excuse about the
amulet.
Yeah, and the text says he's
placated for the moment.
That word placated, it feels too
tidy.
Doesn't.
It it implies the conflict is
resolved.
Exactly.
It's too neat.
I challenge the rider to explore
that tension.
Does is Mark actually believe
them, or does he just realize
he's helpless without them?
That brooding silence shouldn't
be acceptance.
It should be resentment.
A simmering, dangerous
resentment.
He isn't placated.
He's trapped.
He has to work with the people
who failed his sister because
they're his only hope.
That's a much richer, darker
dynamic.
That turns the ending from a
wrap up into a cliffhanger.
It changes his mark from a
simple NPC into a ticking time
bomb.
Exactly.
OK, we've covered a lot of
ground To recap the main advice
here.
First, turn those procedural
failures into atmospheric
tension.
An empty room should feel
threatening.
A failed spell should reveal
something about the world.
Use the failure.
Second, use the environment to
make combat visceral.
Don't just say a room is narrow,
show a sword hitting a wall.
Make it messy.
Let the space affect the action.
3rd Elevate spell descriptions
beyond just mechanics.
Describe the experience of the
magic, the horror of it.
Make it feel real.
And finally, and maybe most
importantly, zoom in on those
crucial dialogue scenes when
trust is broken.
Don't summarize.
Slow down.
Let the silence do the work.
I really want to encourage the
listener here to treat the
session log less like a record
and more like a story that needs
to be shaped.
It's easy to transcribe your
notes, but the art is in
interpreting them.
And honestly, I'm really curious
to see how that tension with is
Mark plays out.
That brooding silence is a
powder keg.
It absolutely is.
I'd strongly encourage them to
submit the next sessions log.
I want to see if they can
maintain that resentment it.
Definitely feels like the party
is walking on thin ice with him
now.
We look forward to reading what
comes next.
Thank you for tuning in to the
critique.
Keep.
Writing session 26.
All right, so here's the setup.
The party teams up with his
Mark, the town's new leader, to
go back to Valaki.
Their mission is a super high
stakes heist.
They've got to steal a holy
artifact from Lady Walker's
house.
First up, the infiltration was a
total mess from the start.
Their magic to find the artifact
totally failed and their stealth
plan fell apart the second they
were inside.
They had to take out guards and
alarm was raised and they were
forced to just rush blindly into
the mansion.
Second, they walk straight into
a magical trap.
Lady walked.
Her summons devils and a vortex
of spectral spirits that just
overwhelms them.
Soon half the team is knocked
unconscious.
The survivors have to start a
fire for a distraction just to
drag their friends over the city
walls and escape.
And finally, this is where the
trust completely breaks down.
Once they're safe is Mark
demands they go rescue his
sister.
But then the party admits the
truth.
They let a mob give her to straw
days ago is Mark is furious.
He realized he was just used as
a pawn and that alliance is left
in absolute ruins.
So yeah, this session was a
catastrophic failure on all
fronts.
They're missing the artifact and
they've shattered a key
friendship.
Battered and exposed, the party
is left with nothing but that
broken alliance and long retreat
to the winery.